tant ce via un endroit qui est très bien
pour parler de tout ça pour continuer à
parler de tout ça c'est le confessionnal
alors dit que jamais confessé ils vont
parce que ça n'existe pas dans notre
religion et là tu vas quand j'entends je
me confesse tout seul tu vas commencer
enrico macias
je crois en dieu mais ce que tu crois au
diable oui parce que je crois toujours
la dualité entre le jour et la nuit le
bien le mal et je crois que l'on peut
représenter aussi bien les forces du mal
que les forces du bien et que c'est pour
reconnaître les vrais valeurs il faut
faut en connaître c'est le mauvais
fruits tu parle souvent du bien que tu
fais du bien que tu essaies de faire
parts et chansons par le message que tu
veux communiquer est ce qui t'arrive de
faire des choses du mal en tout cas
consciemment non mais
inconsciemment malheureusement oui mais
j'essaye de reconnaître mes fautes
lorsque je les fais lorsque je fais du
mal des fois c'est jamais
volontaire mais je peux pas dire que je
suis 1 500% et que je n'ai jamais fait
de mal
ça serait vraiment dégueulasse de ma
part de parler comme ça qui est la
dernière chose de mal que tu fais tu
la dernière chose que j'ai faite c'est
n'avoir pas suivi mon régime